liver King oh so strong liver likes
that's what you are another Fitness
influencer lying how about that the
liver King no what he's not natural he's
been exposed I can't believe it I was
gonna make a video on him a while ago I
just didn't think it was that
interesting but I guess I was wrong it
has almost 2 million followers on
Instagram now he kind of blew up
actually his old shtick is to mimic this
ancestral living of eating raw meats and
livers specifically the only thing I saw
that was that he apparently sleeps on
wood with no mattress the place that
needs to be as pristine as can be you
guys can see see that we sleep on the
ground we have just a little box that I
built just out of some wood to create
some elevation so that the moisture the
humidity in Houston doesn't it's all
about this health and pureness he
doesn't have any Wi-Fi in his hand house
and he openly says many times he does
not take steroids yeah [ __ ] right
okay remember what I said if they if
they don't look natural they're not
natural but of course like any scumbag
influencer he sells supplements that's
right that's the secret gee I wonder
what he lied about not being natural
it's
I wonder why hmm God all right we'll get
into it he was exposed and leaked email
from the channel more plays more dates
Derek exposed and finally he came out
and admitted it with an apology video so
we're gonna have to watch it and I will
review it as an epic apology maker
myself
I'm making this video already zero out
of ten what the [ __ ] is this audio
coming out of my ear can we fix that
side to apologize
because I [ __ ] up
because I'm embarrassed and ashamed
yeah you should be and I misled a lot of
people before social media I was rich
and Anonymous and after social media I'm
still rich but no longer anonymous
the [ __ ] does that have to do with
anything this [ __ ] just flexing
and not just his abs I'm so sorry anyway
I am rich
who told you to say that anyway I used
to be rich and now I'm even richer
thanks to misleading my fans into buying
my supplements fools
you know what if he that's what he said
I would be like holy [ __ ] I love this
man he's
but no I hate you never expected this
kind of exposure in the public eye
all right God damn it we went two
seconds between each line the showing
the leaked email he basically goes
through how his goal was to blow up his
channel get a million followers he had a
film crew blah blah blah blah so now
you're clearly playing for it as a way
to sell your [ __ ] products let's keep
watching to navigate
well
well clearly I did it wrong and I'm here
now to set the record straight
yes
I've done steroids and yes and I'm on
steroids monitored engagements by
trained hormone clinician I don't
understand Sarah's but his [ __ ]
steroid uh where is it his List look
like a [ __ ] crafting thing from
Fallout 3 like what the [ __ ] are all
these drugs the [ __ ] is all
liver King public figure was an
experiment to spread the message to
bring awareness to the 4 000 people a
day who kill themselves that 80 000
people a day that try to kill themselves
our people are hurting at record rates
with depression autoimmune anxiety
[ __ ] stop shut the [ __ ] up so he's
supposed to apologize but really it was
all a noble cause you know I was trying
to save life people are killing
themselves what's the what's the message
why are you saving lives
the reason I made my other video because
I think people don't realize just how
prominent it is for people to use
steroids and it's one of those things
that you know just like it's been talked
about a lot how women have body image
issues because of comparing themselves
to photoshopped images and models and
magazines as men were equally as
susceptible to that and to have a bunch
of people you know in Marvel films
getting buffed taking steroids very
clearly very obviously to anyone that
understands what it means to build
muscle and then come out in interviews
and talk about oh I just had to eat
broccoli and rice it was so tough for me
I wish it's just [ __ ] dishonest and
while also simultaneously Market
different programs Chris Hemsworth
markets his workout video routine
whatever that he sells I don't [ __ ]
care and here we have another one where
he's selling supplements that's really
the reason I don't take steroids
supplements I am saving lives here all
these people trying to get like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about you are the
problem you are not the solution low
ambition in life our young men are
hurting them both feeling lost weak and
submissive so I made it my job to model
teach and preach a simple elegant
solution donate all your money that you
made you said you were already rich
right I'm getting [ __ ] worked up and
we're one minute in all right I've been
on several podcasts and when asked if
I'd ever taken steroids I've always said
no what did you say I don't touch the
stuff not gonna touch the stuff never
touch the stuff and why did you say that
there's no products
that was a lie
[Music]
no one could tell just for like how
weirdly defensive and whatever you
splurred out from then like let's watch
that by the way because it's [ __ ]
funny dude and I'm just gonna head you
know face it head on I don't I don't
touch this stuff I've never done this
stuff I'm not gonna do this stuff the
the ask for the steroids that he talks
you've never taken cigarettes no taking
steroids I've never done Peds other than
prioritize execute and dominate your
life I also just do want to say I think
that him saying that is dangerous you
know I want to set the record straight I
would love the opportunity
so Joe Rogan called him out he was like
yeah that guy clearly is on [ __ ]
steroids Joe Rogan openly admits taking
steroids as well and his response is
that's dangerous for him to say it's a
dangerous message to spread to who dude
there's so many bits at the end of the
day cheating doesn't scale it's not
sustainable and it doesn't scale right
and what I've achieved from a financial
standpoint from a family standpoint
cheating doesn't scale I I can't stand
listening to this [ __ ] I'm not a
competitive athlete of any kind so who
the [ __ ] am I cheating uh your entire
audience you built your entire brand
around being natural ancestral living
like the caveman I don't think the
caveman had or whatever this [ __ ]
shopping list you have is I don't I I
don't know but they didn't have Wi-Fi
and you are blocking Wi-Fi so you are
pretty much on point you know what
I convinced myself
that this topic was a placeholder for a
far more important conversation I
convinced myself that this would
overshadow that 36 years of working out
usually twice a day without PE see that
I actually believe but the thing is no
no one would give a [ __ ] anyone that's
come out and said hey I I take steroids
it's not like people how there you go no
if anything people respect honesty so it
doesn't [ __ ] matter this whole video
I would have been completely fine with
if you didn't make it because he was
caught like the emails was leaked the
response comes out if he for some reason
decided to feel like you know what I
don't like that I've been lying I don't
want to confess I would 100 accept that
and and uh respect that honestly but
this is just so funny performative and
lame and I had convinced myself that
this would be the wrong message to send
to the 15 year old boys no to the little
boy foreign
he had to he had no choice yeah he
literally just dug himself in a hole he
didn't want to confess so he had to go
deeper and deeper and I guess yeah in a
way he probably feels relieved now that
he's out but it's still so [ __ ]
stupid I'm surprised to see this
sentiment being spread so much the fact
that people believed he was not he's all
mind-boggling I can't believe people are
so stupid it's like most people haven't
lift weights they don't know how it
works it's not that weird that people
have no clue that this is not natural
and especially if some people going
around saying no it is natural yeah for
anyone that understands steroids and how
efficient they are yeah it's pretty
obvious but for most people it isn't and
that's how he's able to maintain this
brand so I don't think it's that weird
that people don't know steroids is so
efficient if you take it you get more
muscles and by not working out and just
taking steroids and someone actively
working out and not taking steroids that
they're extremely efficient even if you
take them once you have a huge Advantage
because it's easier to rebuild muscles
that you have gained from steroids so
you could say no I'm not on steroids but
if you've done it once you're in a
different category than everyone else as
well there's a ton of health risks
involved he clearly doesn't talk about
any of those in this video and that's
just the reality of it 85 percent of the
population that suffers from self-esteem
issues I'm part of that statistic this
is why I [ __ ] work myself to death in
the gym this is why I do 12 to 15 blood
burning workouts a week just to feel
like I'm okay no no I'm not buying this
I'm not buying a single [ __ ] word he
says okay so the reason he takes uh
steroids or whatever the [ __ ] is because
he has low self-esteem you don't
I can't emphasize I would say yeah I
sometimes also have low self-esteem that
is not an excuse to take steroid you
know if you just sense I want to take
steroids because it's the right choice
for me whatever the [ __ ] I would buy
that but this whole like oh I have low
self-esteem I have to take steroids no
that's so [ __ ] stupid you're
basically saying that anyone else with
low self-esteem has to take steroids too
I know that doesn't equate but you're
talking about your audience being 15
year old and it's kind of the message
that you're sending out it seems so
common this topic of body dysmorphia for
people that take steroids like I said I
I think I have self-esteem issues
sometimes and I'll tell you what I have
zero self-esteem issues about the way I
look I look [ __ ] good this is what
zero percent body does morphia looks
like all pure G fuel baby code PewDiePie
I want to motivate other people to work
out as well not to look a certain way
necessarily but because it makes you
feel good I think it's dangerous to
spread this message with with steroids
because ignoring all the negative
effects from it for me eat at least I
can't wrap my head around you're gonna
have to become dependent on it right you
know you're going to the gym and you see
amazing progression because you're on
steroids and it probably feels amazing
but you're stuck in that cycle forever
because you're always going to want to
gain more and more and more and more you
know once you go off steroids you're
gonna go to the gym and you're gonna
actually lose muscle You're Gonna Lose
strength drastically once you do it once
you're pretty much trapped to keep doing
it so it doesn't make sense for me at
all I respect People's Choice to doing
it but I I can't wrap my head around it
to be honest and his message here just
[ __ ] sucks Above All Else
the loyalty
notice how I'm pointing down usually and
if he was truly based he would do the
same but of course he's not there is no
Parallax it's only this line that
matters now if you want to uh watch some
actual really good Fitness motivators I
know that you guys are let down by the
liver King you're gonna have to find
your new one I got your back kiriakos
Kappa kulak the goat 100 big follow this
guy instead no [ __ ] Liberty
I rate this apology a three out of ten
at least you came clean with some things
but in all in all it [ __ ] sucks this
video is sponsored by
yes
[Music]
get three guesses wrong it's nordvpn as
we already established nordvpn greatest
VPN but not just nordvpn nordvpn is more
than VPN they should use that we all
know you can use a VPN to connect to
different countries so you can watch
different streaming shows online but
they also have private DNS which is
essential for your online security your
internet service provider keeps a public
record of all everything
even for years they're legally required
to do it nor VPN Shields all online
activities look how much better it is
they're always adding new cool features
like dark web monitor instead of having
to go all out of the way to check if
your email has been compromised nor V
Panda support you it's like getting a
gentle massage oh I don't have to worry
about one of a million things anymore
thank you nordvpn it also comes built in
with driver protection which blocks
cyber threats in real time there's no
real good reason why you shouldn't have
it use my link okay I don't want to use
the link
nordvpn.com PewDiePie is a link click
link click the goddamn link it's an
amazing service for a cheap monthly
subscription check it out